For this account, the pattern that emerged for all the expressions for the
balances after a certain number of years, was like this. We take the principle,
the amount initially invested, multiply by 1 plus the interest rate written as
a decimal. And then, take that quantity, that I've written in parentheses to a
power that's equal to the number of times interest has been added to the
account. In this case, since interest is compounded yearly, that would just
equal to the number of years that had passed. Let's try doing something
similar, but with a different situation. Remember Athena? Well, she has $300 to
invest. The interest rate on the account she's going to put it in is 5% per
year, compounded annually. How much money will she have in the account after
four years have passed? Remember that pattern that we were using before.